welcome to ee 380 slightly chaotic this
seems to be all this quarter um
in any case this is this is a sort of
suddenly created uh gathering
uh because uh dimitri made a post to uh
uh um to hacker news
which uh gathered an enormous number of
comments
about uh
uh how he thought that google was uh
dying as a search engine
and so i'm you know suggested what we
should do here is he should start out
and talk a little bit about the um
uh what he found and what he had to say
and then uh danny who is uh the uh
know what do you call yourself i'm the
public liaison for a search
the public liaison person
he was actually uh
a
a publisher long ago of uh a lot of the
uh
seo stuff so he's got a lot of
experience with the particular problems
that we have here
and so
um
i expect that he'll have uh some answers
to questions and some things and then uh
if you all are willing i'd love to uh to
just open it up and have discussions
about what's going on here and what uh
what dimitri found what his experiences
were and what your personal experiences
are
um
right now i think uh
the the uh
positions everyone has is that dimitri
says it doesn't work the way he wants it
to
and danny says well it works the way it
works and it works so
um you know let's try to find out what
what's really going on i don't think uh
i want to see anybody holding uh
positions where uh
which are not supported by evidence
uh and uh are supported by emotion but
beyond that i think anything goes
okay can you tell us what you what you
found and what what was it that
motivated your post
um yeah so
i mean i've
like looking into search and organizing
information on the internet is just
something that i've been doing for for a
while now
um
and this particular post um i think i
wrote this because i saw a lot of people
like there have been a lot of posts
recently saying something along the
lines of google search results are bad
um search quality is declining like
every every like few weeks these have
been popping up especially recently
um
and i just thought that most of them did
not like point out the specific um issue
of like authenticity of content
um so my post was mostly focused on this
idea that people are appending reddit to
their search queries because they don't
believe that most of the results they
get uh are authentic websites or
authentic people that they can trust
and
that was kind of like that was the gist
of of what my post said
okay
and you saw did you do some
experimentation of uh
and to try to establish that or is this
just sort of a general feeling that
you've had
um well yeah this type of thing is hard
to get uh quantitative data on because
it reflects people's psychology so it's
kind of a qualitative thing like
um like we're trying to capture this
idea that
people
don't believe in their search results
anymore um the there is one the
qualitative piece of data that that we
do have is that
um
like reddit searches like the word
reddit in google searches is increasing
or has been increasing
over time
um
like that on itself doesn't like prove
why people are adding reddit to their
queries
but we at least know that people seem to
be adding reddit to their search queries
a lot more
um and i also think that
even though we may not like
i think the
the biggest data points to me is the
fact that this post got so much
attention and so many people saying yes
i agree i relate to this post i do this
like there were like many many people
who
seemed to resonate with what was said
um so like the reddit graph plus all the
qualitative the um
feedback from people i think kind of
supports the idea that of at least the
reddit part of this where people think
results are not trustworthy
so danny you wanted to
up in here and
say a little bit
sure
so
i mean i think the most important thing
you said something like i say it works
and it works fine and
i i don't want to take away from
anybody's concerns if if you don't feel
like google search has been working for
you
me or anybody at google saying well
you're holding it wrong isn't really
going to play well you're not happy with
it
and we want to understand
why so we can see if there's things that
we can do that improve
so i'll share some things about how we
work as we talk here
none of that's really meant to kind of
refute
somebody having a bad experience but i'm
hopefully going to shed some light on
some of the things that are going on and
maybe get to some of the qualitative
stuff that that may want to be out there
um
we'll start with what i thought was the
heart of the post about people wanting
the authentic con content i totally
agree people want to get you know
authentic information they want people
if you do a search for product and
you're looking for reviews about it i
think you want to have people who have
used the product reviewed it
done it on some mythology on how they're
going with it rather than somebody who's
just gone to amazon found five reviews
and listed them all there
that doesn't mean it all has to come
from what it read it necessarily and i
think it's also could be like dismissive
of some sites that do really good work
the post for example
sparked a conversation on reddit where i
saw one person complaining that well
they are getting reviews from the verge
and they don't like that that's not
authentic
because they don't even use the products
and as someone who regularly reads the
verge i know that they've used the
product they do really in-depth type of
things so then i don't know whether that
person is concerned that the content
wasn't authentic because it came from
a large brand at this point and maybe it
was monetized because they had ads to
pay for the people producing the content
and they just preferred content being
authentic because there are no ads and
it's on a forum
that
that kind of range can be all over the
place in how people interpret what
authentic content is but overall yeah i
think people would like to get more of
that
we want to show people more of it we
have a whole series of updates we've
done over the past year that we refer to
as the product reviews update to make
sure that when we're showing people
content for product reviews we're trying
to show people
content from people who've met that kind
of criteria they've actually used the
product they've done in-depth kinds of
research
so
i'm sure there's much more we can do to
improve on that
but i also don't think that you just
take the fact that someone's put reddit
into a search result to say that that
means our search results are not
succeeding and in fact there's some
there's a i think a good argument that
they're actually doing the opposite that
they show that we're very successful
red is a popular site lots of people
like to go to it my kids go to it me not
so much i'm not really at the age i grew
up on i'm not to be out of reddit but
they like it lots of people like it and
apparently the reddit search engine
itself is not very good
that's what i gather from the things i
read over this past day
so people seem to be going to google
also because they know they want the
content that read it already
it's not a question of they went to go
do a google search and they hope just
find something sort of
what what have you got they deliberately
want stuff just from reddit and they're
finding it actually very useful to
instead going to reddit and searching
there to come to google do the search
add in reddit and get the reddit results
that we're providing better than reddit
does because i think we're maybe a
better search engine on that refund
i do a similar type of thing
cutter is a really popular review site
they do really in-depth stuff really i
never want to buy anything if i haven't
found the wire cutter review at this
point right it's like how i used to be
with consumer reports i never felt like
i could buy anything unless consumer
reports have reviewed it
for whatever reason though if i want to
see if wirecutter has written about a
particular product i don't go to
wirecutter and search there
maybe it's because i don't really
remember where their search box is
maybe i've used it before in the past
but i typically would just go to google
type in you know
best product whatever wire cutter
because i know google will get me to the
wire cutter stuff that i wanted it had
nothing to do with me thinking google
wasn't a good search engine because i
put wire cutter into my search it had
everything to do with i could trust
google to get me to the right content by
giving it more information that i wanted
so i think when you look at that sort of
thing or if you look at the rising
usage of reddit and going into queries
that also could be by explained by the
rising popularity of reddit and people
wanting to go there as well
what i don't want to take away is
clearly some people are doing that
because they would like to get more
reddit like or maybe more discussion
oriented type of content that's out
there
and that's something we'll be looking at
more like are we not showing enough of
that should we be shifting to show more
of that kind of material is it more
helpful are there ways we can
automatically detect if our systems and
they all automated everything's produced
automatically
should understand that hey in this kind
of query maybe getting more of this
content from reddit or you know some of
the other forms that are out there would
be more useful because that's a good mix
along with the other kind of content
that we're showing as well
i mean if i should just jump in or yeah
i want to do this
okay
um yeah now i think there there's
definitely a broader point uh here about
people wanting information from specific
websites like some people trust reddit a
lot some people trust otherwise like
some people want a stack overflow answer
specifically for example
um and i think there there is also like
a lot of things that people mentioned in
the comments as well as this idea that
lots of the information they used to
find while searching is now like locked
behind
private communities like
the discussions are happening in discord
chats and private communities that
people can't access anymore through
through google or any other search
engine for that matter
um and i think a lot of people
um like yeah a big piece of this is
people wanting that community
information or that community discussion
that they can't find anymore and reddit
is one of the last websites left where
they can find it
so that's like part of the reason behind
this old yeah reddit uh or another
website situation
um
but i do think that at at the same time
i i
would think that it should be reasonable
that if i search something in google
without appending reddit i should still
expect to get results that are worth
clicking
um and of course search quality is very
debatable we can talk about what
equality results actually means i would
be curious to hear
like your take on how google actually
thinks about a quality result as well
um
but
i think it is like reasonable enough to
expect if i search for a product review
or for a food item without appending
some specific website that i already
know has an answer that i should get a
good result and just to provide a really
specific example
um i wish i had time to actually make
the slides for this but i did go look up
some specific queries
um and i found like like one one
interesting thing i found is there's a
search engine called you.com um it's
kind of kind of new
but basically i searched for
uh lenovo
like uh i searched for like a laptop
review basically
um and in google the first result said
yeah these like
big corporate sites filled with ads and
view.com they also have like very
similar websites but u.com does this
thing where they extract
the actual information from the page
which i think solves one of the other
big complaints people have and the big
issue people have is that
the first step results on
google are like filled with ads and once
again this applies to probably many
search engines but they're like the
first set of results are these pages
that are a very bad user experience i'm
not sure who would consider it to be a
high quality result unless you have an
ad blocker on but we should
ideally be able to use the web without
ad blockers um so what u.com does to
solve this problem is just extract the
actual information so we don't have to
look at ads like that's like one example
solution
um
and then another oh
sorry did you say so you did the search
and they got all the information you
needed from the website so you didn't
have to click on the website at all
yeah like
and in the case of you.com they're able
to give me the lenovo review without
like the
the actual page of the websites or
filtered ads and like sales links to a
bunch of things it's like this is what
people are complaining about when they
say google results are bad they mean
like they mostly mean like the web is
bad perhaps
um but like this seems like a solvable
problem if like u.com could summarize i
know google does this as well for some
results where they extract information
and try to provide these
like chunks that give you what you
actually search for
um
so that's kind of like one example of a
thing that i see
that google is not doing that perhaps it
could be doing
um
if we
took
entire content from websites so that you
didn't have to visit the websites i
think that you would find people would
scream at google and say how can you
destroy websites and their business
model for existing and i don't i don't
really understand how
something like a u.com if they're doing
that like you said when i do a search it
should be reasonable i should find
things that make me feel like i should
click on them which i would take to
learn more and the people producing that
content are probably hoping you're going
to come to their website as well
and all those ads and all that clutter
is what's paying for their time to
produce the content that
you were receiving for free
so then to have a party go through and
strip all that away
i don't
know how the people who produced the
content that you wanted in the first
place then get to continue to produce
the authentic content you want because
they authentically don't have any money
to do it
but so that's
one reason why we wouldn't tend to do
that because we want to support an
ecosystem to do that so
um but i'd love to know the actual query
if you want to send it later i'll take a
look
but you had said something about how do
we evaluate search quality i could talk
more about that if you want but i didn't
want to
you were still talking so i do want to
ask that one thing but i want to cut you
off from the breath first
sure and just a quick response to that
like i i agree that like there's another
problem here which is monetization on
the internet and i agree that's taking
away like traffic from websites is not
necessarily good but
um
but i'm
i i might be wrong about this but i i
believe that google does this to very in
various search categories like song
lyrics like not like these knowledge
chunks for like certain factual pieces
of information like there's various
search categories where google does this
exact thing so i'm not sure
like what
what is the line that you're using if we
have a license agreement to do it we
would show more than sort of fair use
kinds of snippets
with song lyrics we license songs lyrics
sports scores we license that
we're paying money to someone to produce
that kind of content and allow it to
reproduce it in full
if there's real basic factual
information that we can understand from
across the web it's facts and
you know
the height of the empire state building
isn't really a
a fact that you know it's like a fact
that exists in the world
so
that's how we we kind of balance it you
you want to be a good citizen with the
ecosystem you want to make sure the
ecosystem kind of
kind of thrives so i mean speaking for
us that's how we operate
yeah um yeah i mean i guess you also
wrote data fair use like i'm not sure
exactly how much content counts as fair
use i'm not sure if u.com
is doing fair use or if they actually do
have deals with these
websites maybe um
um but yeah i guess i guess therefore
there's there are ways to get it done um
but there are different trade-offs like
it might cost money or yeah
um
anyway i totally get the idea that if we
deliver people this is what i said
before if we deliver someone to a
product review at the verge and the
verge has ads that are paying for the
content and people don't like the ads
because they just i don't want any ads
then it's like okay
you can perceive our search results are
bad even though the content was great
simply because you didn't like the
content that was out there now we
actually have some guidelines that we do
provide out to
people to say look if you have ad heavy
sites we may not rank those as well if
we take all things into account we've
got content that's equal of nature but
one is not sort of intrusive ads and you
get a bunch of pop-ups and all that sort
of stuff
then you know that's where we're trying
to nudge the ecosystem to say look get
get the balance right and that sort of
thing
um
but but to speak to the general search
quality process um
of the things we do with anything that
we launch is it goes through an
evaluation process and in particular we
use what we call human search quality
raters
and
you can go to our house search work site
and if you type in house search work
reddit on google you won't find it but
if you type in how search works
google you will find it
maybe you'll find it on reddit as well
sorry
but it explains more about how the
process works but basically
we
want to make an update to our our search
algorithms maybe we want to find a
better way of showing product review
content so we've got a sample queries
that we're we're generating and we're
having human beings do the search
this is what we're doing now this is
what we're doing with our you know
hopefully new and improved search
systems that we've developed you're
seeing them side by side rate the
results that you're getting did this
seem to satisfy your query that does not
satisfy your query was this helpful
authoritative information was this not
was this you know all sorts of things
and we have this like guide that the
raiders have to use it's like
200 300 pages long
and it's great reading because i've read
it
but anybody can read it and we publish
it for anybody on the web to do it and
everybody who is a raider
um has to have gone through that guide
so that everybody's reading from the
same set of common criteria which is
explaining to them this is how we're
trying to determine if a search result
is a quality or not in a methodological
way
in a way that's you know going across
everything that's out there
so that all happens and we go through
and if the improvement looks positive
from a search quality thing as verified
by these human raiders i mean we have
like 10 000 human raiders that are used
so it's not just like one raider if that
improvement looks like it's improved the
search quality as judged by
ordinary human beings
then we'll go forward with the
improvement and that's how we we figure
out if the search quality that we think
our algorithmic and machine learning
systems are doing are matching what a
human being would like and if they don't
seem to be doing it so anytime we make a
change it's because some human review
process like that has said
this seemed to be a good
good improvement
all that said
nothing is ever perfect so if you make
some changes you can get some losses as
well and then we go through and we try
to go through the process again to see
how we can improve it and make a better
thing with it from there
now to give you a sense of how that
works like if you want to look at third
party um
one of the links i shared it with the
response back to you and i'm trying to
see if i have the um
the url with it i'll find it later but
when this sort of thing happened oh it
said surge hq dot ai and you go from
there and look at the blog and i'm sure
you'll find it but
you know you had mentioned that this
kind of happens on um hacker news we've
had threads like this before so when one
of these things happened earlier this
year
serge hq they they do the same kind of
process we do but they're a third party
and they're independent and they're just
trying to measure well how how is search
quality from a a qualitative type of
thing let's get a lot of data
and
they ran a bunch of queries us and being
up against each other and went through
it and the results came back that it was
like 80 of our search results were
deemed to be amazing or good like
that's pretty good i i'd like it to be
90 like 99 but you know qualitatively
speaking
that data was really helpful only one
percent of the people said that our
research results were bad it was like 15
they're like it's okay you could do
better so yeah i'd like to see us
improve on that but
that
speaks to the search results being
pretty good not us just saying it but
this third-party kind of saying that
all that said
all that said i again don't want to take
away from the perception that
for people who are doing these searches
and just feeling it's not getting what
they want done
and it's not happening as well from them
one of the thoughts i tend to feel that
especially with sort of the hacker news
group
is that i think there's a lot of
programmers and software engineers and a
lot of people who are developers a lot
of people are doing very very technical
queries
and i suspect that part of them might be
that when they're doing these kinds of
searches that
they are sometimes getting results that
are coming back because we're going
broader from the words that they
indicated or conversely
that they're already feeling like they
need to control the queries so much that
they're doing a lot of quoting and a lot
of requiring and kind of overriding the
the ranking systems we're already trying
to use
um both of which are our challenges
neither of which i want to then say
dismisses their concerns but i think
that's part of why it might resonate so
much with them and we need to do a
better job especially for that group and
we need to do a better job for everybody
but we do need to do a better job so
that when you know these things come up
people on hacker news maybe feel more
inclined to say actually it's been
pretty good right
that would be our goal
yeah i guess as we're on the
as around this this particular topic i
guess this would be a good time to talk
about this exact matching issue that
people have brought up
um if anyone is not aware the issue is
some like in google if you code
something it is meant to do an exact
match for that coded phrase or word
whatever it is
um and some people are complaining that
this exact matching is not even working
anymore google is just coming up with
random results to keep them on google
and people have all their theories
and danny has pointed out that like it's
not necessarily that exact match does
not work it is that
uh the way in which it works is just a
bit confusing to people because of
things like punctuation and alt text and
like
parts of the document that people may
not like expect to
be searching when they type their exact
search query
um so like and i've looked at like many
possible examples it seems every example
can be traced to some
like
very some issue with punctuation or
there's text somewhere
hidden on the page that
doesn't necessarily look like it should
be an exact match but turns out to be
because of the way that
the text is tokenized so it's kind of
like um i like i would say
um the feature is just so unintuitive
that people passionately believe that it
doesn't work even though it kind of does
just because i guess the maybe it's more
of a like ui ux failure here when people
don't understand how to use it and
they're like so mad at google because of
this so maybe you can
yeah just like give your thoughts on
this exact matching situation
let me start back on one thing you said
like i guess one of the things is like
so we've done that to keep people on
google there's no
i sometimes people say this and i i'm
like there's no advantage to us keeping
you on google like
nothing happens if you do more searches
it doesn't
make us
better necessarily right maybe it
frustrates you and you don't want to
search with us more
and if you just stay on the page i don't
know that that helps so it's like our
our goal is to get you to information as
quickly as we can get you to the
information so making you do more
searches or whatever definitely not but
not a thing
what happens is i think by default when
people do searches on google we are
going to
gently try to match all the words as
closely as they entered but we're going
to go beyond the words and also look for
synonyms or related concepts as well
that's really important because
a lot of the content people are seeking
is written differently than the way that
they search so i somebody yesterday and
this came up on the hacker news thread
was searching on how to disassemble
their suv i hope i'm pronouncing that
all right i'm not the cook in the family
but i know my son got one for um
christmas now that's all it was doing
was the whole time i'm going to sue you
this it seems like an all-day process
anyway
they'd search for disassembly and in
fact they searched for every single word
and they put it in quotes because they
really absolutely positively thought
what they needed to have would be a page
that had all those words and the word
they used was disassembly um
and there was literally no page that we
know of on the internet that matched all
those words
but if they hadn't done that the
disassembly i think would have
synonymized to something like take apart
or clean and that was the instruction
manual which is what you get if you've
done it without all the the queries so
it's important for us to go beyond the
exact terms
because
people don't even know sometimes the
term that they're using that's another
example of this and we use this all the
time somebody does a search for
that movie with the guy on the island
and the volleyball and we'll figure out
that that's um castaway right
those aren't words in the title of the
movie but we can figure it out
conceptually and that's the match and
when that kind of thing happens like
even i'll go wow that was pretty cool we
did a pretty good job on that
but when we get that wrong and i think
especially if you are after something
especially technical if we get that
wrong or we're perceived to getting it
wrong absolutely agree then i think
there's the frustration that happens so
when these quoted searches happen we are
going to match
we're going to find content that has
that exact word or that phrase
but there are some cases where because
we drop the punctuation out a good
example like if you search for dog cats
quote dog cats we should find those two
words in that order next to each other
but if a page says dogs comma cats
we will match that page because we don't
see the comma we just see it as a space
and so that's a match as well and it's
apparently really really complicated for
us not to consider you know to consider
the punctuation like really really hard
like
one of our top engineers spent yesterday
looking at some of the stuff i sent him
and he came back he's like yeah that's
really hard that's probably not going to
happen
but what we can do and i think what we
used to do and that would have helped is
that when we do a snippet to try to
explain to you why a page is relevant to
your query
we get to do a better job of showing you
the quoted
aspect and i think we haven't been doing
that because as you mentioned sometimes
the quoted parts are in pages where
there's just not really good information
to snip but they don't tell you much
about it and to us that's not a very
good snippet but actually if those words
were really important to you and you had
quoted to them
knowing exactly where they appeared on
the page reinforces to you that no we
weren't crazy and and ignored it
entirely but we found it so
that's definitely something we'll look
at hard can we get that back in there so
it closes some of that intuitive gap
that's out there as well
um
anyway i kind of rambled on it from
there and i see a hand went up too so
[Laughter]
we have a question on the uh on the
board here it it just listening to this
it seems to me that and then please
excuse me for being logical but
it seems to me that there's um you know
either there's
something
better than google
which will displace google
or
people just get tired of search
and just don't do it anymore
or
everybody's frustrated because their
expectation level
has gone
up
and it's the expectations are surpassing
what
technology can deliver
so
you know i
personally i don't you i try not to use
google search i use duckduckgo because i
i'm more concerned about privacy
[Music]
but
i find that
duckduckgo does not do a good as good a
job as google and sometimes
to get something done i'll go and use
google but anyway it's just the idea of
people are making a choice
and either there's something to choose
between or there's some kind of
frustration and and google is becoming
seen as a utility
and people are treating it like pg e
anyway i'll just leave that on the table
for both of the presenters to comment on
well tons to say but i i i yield to
dimitri first if you would like to say
something
i'm sure
um all right yeah uh so you made it a
point that they're like either some
there's something better than google
that will displace it or people just get
tired of searching i'll do it anymore or
and i guess one
one thing
uh that i would say there is i do think
that google i think i think a lot of the
problems that are faced by google are
also faced by most of the other big like
bing that go like they all have a bunch
of seo spam in their first results by
some people's definition of seo spam
um
so i think it's not like a google issue
it might
might just be an issue with the way that
most people have thought about search
because most search engines like are
just some kind of copy of google
everyone is thinking about search in the
same way and they've been thinking about
it in this exact same way for the last
like 20 years or so
and i think the search engine that is
better than google will probably not
look like google like
um i think we will need to rethink what
search is on this version of the
internet and the way things are right
now
um maybe that means like one one like
one possibility there to throw out a
concrete example is like a social search
engine
where you have
you can say i trust this person and all
the websites they trust
um or i trust recommendations from this
person
um or maybe there's something where you
can connect all these private
channels that you're in so you can
search your own discords and
friend groups and all these private
communities you're in and that's your
search engine
um i think there's lots of possibilities
for what
how to build like better search but i
wouldn't say it's like better than
google it like the
search engine that really tries a new
paradigm would be better than all of
them because they all do the same thing
right now i think
well
dmitry don't you think that the
part of the problem lies in the fact
that the indexes and index of symbol
symbols
uh possibly with some synonym
replacement
and that we think in terms of semantics
so the meaning of what things is what's
important for us as opposed to the
string of characters
um i mean i i think google i like if
anything google has mastered the idea of
semantic search and
like typing in words and getting things
that do not match the exact
like you can type in yeah like movie
with the person on the boats and it will
probably figure out like what movie
you're referring to
um so i think i think that's something
that
like that's something that is like a
double-edged sword because when it works
it feels really good but it doesn't work
it feels like there's no way to correct
correct it which is what people were
complaining about as well it's like oh
if google's ai thinks that i meant this
even though i type these literal words
and this is what i actually meant but
google thinks i was talking about
something else because they think
they're smarter than me
um like that's what people are mad at
but like when it works it feels like
magic
great
i think i think you're right and it is
magic
um
you know you're much too young to
remember the days when we didn't have
one
or a search engine that worked do you go
through
a list of no four or five
thousand
hits
to see if you could find something that
you wanted to find
well i'm not too young to remember that
they they were very magical when they
came up um which is part of the reason
just to go back because as mentioned on
my career before i mean i used to be a
journalist
and when i would do searching as a
journalist i would use things like
lexisnexis and it would require me to
know very arcane language where i would
go through and have to define dates and
i would have to go through and define
sources and all the words i thought
could possibly be in there to get the
matches and then somebody had to pay an
extremely high amount of money for all
the searches that we would do as
journalists
and then i had left to do web
development and then
started writing about how search engines
operate and i would cover both the
search marketing aspect but also the
impact of search engines on lives and
how they operated from a technological
basis and i did that for 20 years i ran
two different websites about it
um
and so and then i had gotten tired of
writing about search engines i couldn't
write another article about meta tags to
save my life i thought so um i retired
but then google quickly said well no you
can't retire you need to come explain
search more and i ended up here but what
i will say is
search engines to me i love them and i
love the technology and they've been
revolutionary for people in ways that i
think those who have grown up on them
simply don't recognize
or even if you're a publisher having
been someone who was at a newspaper they
went through a newspaper war and had to
spend money to try to get people to come
to them and then today
you can create a news blog and you can
receive people coming to your website
for free through a search engine you get
those kinds of connections
it it's it's miraculous it's so good
that we do take it for granted
but
then to come back to i think some of the
things that were mentioned so first of
all on the duckduckgo thing in the
privacy well i certainly hope you would
come back to google and try us again as
well um we are a private search engine
we're not handing out your search data
to people so you know
your your searches don't go anywhere
they stay with us you don't have to have
any of your search activity logged if
you don't want to do it if you want it
you can do it it's like auto save i like
to have things auto saved it saves me
from losing work but that's sort of down
to you
um
but you know aside from the privacy
aspect
one of the reasons you'll probably find
a difference in the search results that
we do versus say a duckduckgo which
really i think relies heavily on being
we make a huge investment in search
we do a lot a lot of work to make sure
we're showing trustworthy information so
if you do a search for like coveted
vaccines are dangerous we're going to
show you really trustworthy information
and we've invented in systems to try to
identify that gosh even though we could
match those exact words are we exacting
are we also matching pages that are
trustworthy or helpful or showing
expertise or authority or that you know
are reliable for this type of thing that
we refer to as a money or your life
query where your money or your life
depends on it
that is a huge investment and it's a
really big thing and there's a lot of
work that goes into it
then i think it was the question of well
what happens because people either get
frustrated and give up or something else
takes over from google what wasn't
mentioned is that we just keep improving
because that's what we should be doing
we're not going well
everybody's frustrated and i guess
they'll just have to stay frustrated and
i guess that's it
like
we're not sitting around just saying
well that's it it's all done
there's nothing else for us to do
google was not the first search engine
to come onto the web
and google in the time that i covered it
externally and in the time i've been to
it now
never sits around and says well that's
it we've got it all wrapped up
there's a great deal of sense of
the greatest new thing could be around
the corner if we don't keep improving
ourselves we have to prove ourselves
every day with every query so something
like this has happened now
i have seen happen where people have
been frustrated about google search
results
five years ago and google will go
through and make improvements or 10
years ago and then google goes through
and makes improvements and thank
goodness it does make improvements
because it's a good search engine i'd
like to see it grow
and i'd like to see it succeed because i
think it's been
great and also because what i think's
also said is if you have this thing you
use it and you like it you trust it you
don't want to see it go away i think you
do kind of want to root for it and that
goes back and i did mention that i'm old
but
if everybody else is old too you'll
remember alta vista and i would wager
that a number of people here used to use
alta vista and it would also age their
number you shifted over to google and
when people would ask you what search
engine you were using you probably said
something along the lines of
well i used to use alta vista but now
i'm with google i heard that so much you
have to joke about it it was like saying
someone had broken up with a partner
well we were married but you know it
didn't work out
no one wanted to leave all the vista all
the events that just didn't keep
improving
google does not want to do that we want
to make sure we're constantly improving
and so we hear things like this we take
it really seriously it's like how do we
keep improving because we want to keep
showing ourselves to people so they can
trust that we're going to be delivering
on what they want to have happen
so
i would enter that in as among the
things that would be possible to happen
i did also want to remark on the whole
expectations things because and again
because i feel so old and covering all
this for so long
i used to teach people how to use search
engines when they first started and you
actually had to do such a thing right
today nobody thinks about how do i use
the search engine where's the
instruction manuals do i need to read
anything it's like just go here's the
box you start searching
people you have to do searches sometimes
you do boolean searches and we would
deal with parentheses and all that sort
of stuff or whatever and one of the
things i found remarkable is that people
would search and search for things and
if they couldn't find it they blamed
themselves
the search engine was never at fault it
was the person i just don't know what
i'm doing
i don't know why i can't find it i
watched one person try to find the phone
number for a place to get the operating
hours and this was like in 98 or
whatever right so they were searching
the information wasn't even available on
the web
at that point and what i said was look
you could just call 4-1-1 for the phone
number
and then call the place and they'll tell
you if they're open but that person
spent like 10 minutes trying to figure
it out and in the end blame themselves
when the reality was it wasn't their
fault it wasn't the search engine's
fault the information just wasn't there
but i do think there's been this shift
because the search engines have gotten
so much better
that now
we really expect them to find everything
even if it's not there and if you don't
find it why didn't you find it it's your
fault and you failed and that is
absolutely not meant to mean
it was actually the user's fault and we
don't need to worry about that or
whatever because in the end our job as a
search engine is not to leave the user
frustrated we need to try to find ways
to communicate to them so they
understand what's going on
that can be things like
you can do some queries and we'll tell
you hey like it's like a new message we
introduced this year to say hey
we've got some results that match all
those words you entered
we just don't know if they're that good
but this is just the best we've got and
by the way
here are some tips you might want to try
because we've done you've done all you
can do we've done all we can do with
this kind of query but maybe if you need
some of these tips and use some of these
other things
we can get some more information we can
kind of help you get to where you're
kind of looking for so maybe we'll do
some more of that type of stuff as well
i we don't want people to be frustrated
and if their expectations have gone up
we need to ride through the expectations
as well as best we can yeah hi um
i just have a an anecdote um i know it's
probably one of everybody's got a dozen
of these but my um
i've been on the web for building on
building websites on the web for 25 plus
years followed danny's career and
watching uh learning about search engine
optimization from him and from
uh
some of his uh
articles over the years but
the
the thing that just came up recently in
my life is searching for
um
an rv trip which we've never taken an rv
before we want to do a big summer
vacation my wife who is not technical um
had done about three or four i would
call them
sessions of research using google uh to
try and find out all of the things that
we don't know
about taking a trip in an rv
um and there's just a ton of
knowledge that we feel like we have to
catch up on what it is that we're going
that we're getting ourselves into
and
on her third or fourth session of doing
this she asked me is there a
a search tool that i should use other
than google because she was frustrated
by
the results that she seemed to be coming
across over and over and over again in
her searching and again we're i'm
talking about a wide range
of search terms uh partly because we
don't know what we don't know yet and
we're learning as we're researching this
topic
and she was
she said to me that it felt like all she
got the results on were sites that were
filled with ads themselves and were
focused on trying to get her into the
into their purchase pipeline you know
into that
which at this point in our
research that's not where we wanted to
be we wanted to have more broad general
knowledge about uh these types of trips
and we do want authentic
uh i i think the term that um demetria
and his um paper talked about was that
authentic stuff um that was lacking in
the search results and and still is
something we're struggling to find um i
think i'm gonna append reddit on to a
couple of my queries
uh so that's all i wanted to say and see
if there's uh thoughts about that
the authentic stuff
so first of all i'm sorry we weren't
getting more of the authentic content to
it um we actually have things that are
trying to appear sometimes and we
understand that someone's going on a
search journey that's the kind of word
we would use as well and you're doing
these repeated queries and we're trying
to help you be able to pick up from
where you left off
so you can kind of keep advancing on it
so and if you think of some of the
queries you want to share them later i'd
love to take a look at them to see what
we can do
some of the stuff we've done with the
product review stuff we might try to
expand that more these things aren't
necessarily products but kind of
are akin to that type of thing like you
know
like exactly what you were sort of going
through
um
so we can find a way to improve on that
you know we'll look at it i think
one of the biggest challenges is also
that's out there though is this thing
what i mentioned before who's writing
the content
right like
if this were 10 years ago
um ideally you'd have someone who'd gone
on an rv journey and wrote you a whole
checklist of all the things that there
was to do
right and that's a lot of work and
i don't know that everybody's producing
that kind of content i'll give you
another example i took a trip out to
tunisia once with my oldest son and we
went to visit star wars places out in
tunisia
which is amazing like you know here's
luke skywalker's house we're standing
out front and
i
learned some things on the web and i
still want to go through and write up
this whole post to explain how anybody
can do this because it was an incredible
experience i just haven't found the time
because i gotta write the blog post i
gotta edit it i get the photos up i
gotta do all this sort of work
now i tweeted about it
i did a whole twitter thread because it
was very easy for me to put that
together it's very easy content creation
in that regard so part of the challenge
i think we have is
if people aren't doing these kinds of
blogs of authentic types of things like
they kind of may be used to then how do
we do a better job of bringing it in
from places where things have moved one
of the things places where people are
doing is there's a lot more short-form
videos how do we bring more of that
stuff in or
maybe we do need to bring in more as i
said before of the stuff where people
are sharing experiences in foreign
places and perhaps we've been just
lacking on that we've got to get more of
that stuff back in there
dmitry
tell us a couple of things about you
you're you have a project that you have
in progress
and you might tell us where you are i
have no idea
one of the amazing things about the
internet is i called you up and you were
there
uh
yeah usually i'm in san francisco but
right right now i'm i'm in the trinidad
and tobago
um which is a place in the caribbean
where i'm from
um
and yeah the other thing i guess yeah
the relevant thing that i'm working on
is a blog directory called blogsurf
um it's meant to be a directory of
personal blogs
um right now it's just like a collection
of all these blogs and various
categories
um but soon we'll hopefully have a
search engine as well so you can search
all these blog posts
and i think uh
like also to respond to the question
about the this rv search story
um
i think that
like i would i would call into question
the the the
assertion that there is no authentic
content to be found on this topic
um
i think like
like it appears to me that google
prioritizes these big media publications
and these more corporate websites that
tend to be more ad heavy in their first
results um i can give an example query
for this as well
um but like if you go to like page six
or seven of girl results then you might
finally find a blog or some type of
real person who is just writing about
the experience so i'm not sure
like what
like why exactly that result is so low
quality um maybe the person who is just
blogging about their experience does not
care about seo and did not do some basic
things that would help them get ranked
higher in google
um but yeah i mean i'd be curious to
hear danny's thoughts on this on like
why
why it appears from the outside that
these like big publications are always
the top even if there seems to be like a
good quality normal post by a normal
person like page six
um so i'm not saying that there's not
that content that's out there i'm saying
possibly there's less of it that there
was in the past and possibly is good
content out there but it's in places
outside of ordinary web pages where
we've typically looked at
i also think that um
i also think that
you
it's a difficult thing like i did it
very quickly like how to plan an rv trip
across the us right and i've got a thing
called the getaway couple
i'm gonna guess that the getaway couple
has gone out there and discovered that
hey this is a really cool thing for us
to write about i haven't read read the
easy because we're on the thing or
whatever i also see somebody called the
rolling pack here's how to plan it
it's these kinds of things you've seen
before these are affiliate links here's
some things to kind of keep in mind
and there's another thing called our rv
share
and i think the difficulty is they've
learned how to earn money producing that
kind of content and so we can then
dismiss it as well it's not a authentic
but it might very well be perfectly good
and helpful authentic content that's
just how they're making a living to do
it
right
i did a lot of hiking during the
pandemic
i was doing searches for hiking near me
in southern california and i constantly
constantly got to a website called the
hiking guy and he's got a wonderful
website
it's the exact kind of content you would
want to find i had no difficulty getting
to that content at all told me
everything i needed to know about places
to go all the details or whatever and
yet
he had affiliate links and he has
information and i'm like thank goodness
you have that i hope you're earning
money i actually sent him money and did
a donation because i was like you're
doing such good content i want you to be
successful with it but someone else
might have landed on his website and
said wow this is somebody who
generated good content as a start
continued to develop it up to they could
do a business about it and now we're
going to decide it's not authentic
that's
why
i don't want to take away from the fact
that there's absolutely gold quality
content that's out there and that we
probably need to do an even better job
on it
and
maybe again that means that there are
times when we should be surfacing
content from reddit because that is the
most useful content or
other places that are out there where
people are sharing experiences i think
that's been one of the big takeaways
we've certainly had off of this is that
people want to hear even more from
really community sites where people are
sharing tips and all that sort of stuff
that's
really well heard and i think we do need
to make improvements in that regard but
there's nothing in the system that's
designed to say yeah that's a big site
just make the big site go up
like that that's not how the system
works it's not really looking at signals
in that kind of manner um it's really
designed to try to look at
what do we think is the most relevant
helpful trustworthy authoritative
information we have as validated by what
human reviewers tell us as well
when we put it up against their thing so
danny you just translate
don't blame the search engine on the
information that gets put up on the web
but i don't want to translate that way
and i think it's really poor if our of
our response is hey we just reflect
what's on the web
which has been a responsive we've
sometimes said
sometimes sometimes the content isn't
there and there's not good content but
sometimes the content is there and we
just need to figure out where it's now
residing or if it's not residing we need
to then think about are there more
things we can do to support an ecosystem
that they want to put it out on the open
web that they want to share can we make
it easier for the content to be there
because people want it so yeah i don't i
don't want to just blame the web and say
well
i think it's perfectly fair by the way
let's have a quick quick comment in
response to to that like it seemed it's
like well maybe this is a bad
translation but it seems like what what
you actually just said is
the corporate and big publications are
on top because the black box algorithm
says these are the best websites the
black box algorithms which are judged by
some group of people who evaluate search
qualities said these are good therefore
like that is what is on top
um
so i guess in response that i think a
lot of the people who resonated with
this post would probably say something
like who are these people who who are
evaluating your algorithm if they
actually think these s these like spam
filled corporate sites are the best
results
though the the verge isn't a spam filled
corporate site and i've got someone on
reddit saying that they don't like them
for their product reviews
i
that the hiking blog that i mentioned is
not a spam filled site
some of these rv things
very briefly are spam filled sites
they're probably really helpful sites
sure like not every we're not saying
every result has these like big
publications but if you search for like
a recipe for example
a lot of the results will be these big
rest like these big sites and if you go
to page six you'll find like these
smaller more personal personal blogs and
maybe those people are making money and
like whatever too but
and i and i would say i don't know that
the qualitative data is it's always the
bulk of the sites that are going like
that as well and the reason i would say
that to you is because when we make a
change
we will hear from people who run the
small sites if it has not been helpful
to them
there are lots of people who run small
sites and we invest huge amounts of
resources to make sure anybody of any
size site can be successful we don't
have special support options just for
the big people
we don't even charge for it it's for
everybody that's out there we want
everybody to succeed so the systems are
not designed to change just reward the
big kinds of sites that out there the
raiders by the way the raiders are just
ordinary people that are hired that go
through a training process and the
ratings never go directly into search
results they don't rate an individual
page and say well that's a
10 out of 10 make sure you rank it
better they just sort of validate
whether the model is corresponding to
what these readers kind of do they're
kind of like a check on it so their
ratings don't go directly back into
search in any way you couldn't do it
like there's trillions of pages and they
change all the time
so there that's not what's happening
with it there's ordinary people who
follow the guidelines anybody can read
and say
these things gave us helpful information
and we share that with everybody to say
this is what we'd like to do with
helpful information one of the things
i've seen by the way like this is like
with the sorry i'm going on but like um
like with the recipes we've seen people
complain like i just i don't want the
whole story that's going on right like
just give me the recipe and it was like
one woman dead pearlman so she has a
whole recipe blog that um she runs
called smitten kitten and she is like
look
your recipe writer
you write whatever you want this is not
a just shut up and be in the kitchen
cook type of situation you're providing
the recipes you want to provide a story
that goes along with it you should do it
don't let anybody tell you you shouldn't
do that sort of thing
and i don't kind of know how you deal
with the balance there because then you
have other b why just learn the recipe
so then they don't like it even though
it might be a totally authentic recipe
and somebody's got a story that they
want to tell you about with it
and maybe it's that we need to be a
little bit more tolerant all around
things
i don't know it's a challenge
we have over here in the corner it's
been waiting patiently i think you
already answered my question danny but
i'll just to make
sure um
let's say
so i'll pay you back off your hiking
example from earlier
where you gave an example of a hiking
website that had affiliate links that
still offers really good information um
but
let's say that there are two hiking
websites and one offers good information
without any affiliate links
and
there's the one that you were talking
about which offers good equally good
information with affiliate
with affiliate links um
would google
qualify those as equally like if they if
the information was
basically equal google would
basically
rank those as being equal
we really wouldn't look at the affiliate
links present and then say well we could
put you down because you had affiliate
links just like we wouldn't look at oh
we can understand there's ads so
therefore you're not as good as the one
without ads
we would understand if you seem to um
have
a huge amount of intrusive ads that's
part of what we call our page quality
page called anything of the name our
core web vitals type of thing that we
try to understand
and then we communicate about as well
but just the mere presence of
monetization wouldn't cause us to say
okay well the other person gets the bump
with it
okay
thanks
okay does anybody else have something
they want to say
i think put the hand up
thank you very much for coming to speak
to us i was wondering um in relation to
the ongoing conversation on trust in the
internet if you could talk more
specifically about the developer
experience particularly for searching
for help i know in many of the hacker
news spreads which i'm sure you've read
there have been significant complaints
about uh first of all spam sites
outright copying good of issues stack
overflow etc i know i and my boss have
very long new black lists that take out
the whole first page of google results
sometimes for this um and then of course
uh spam sites copying and pasting terms
help pages that are not authoritative
and
to the point where the official help
page is for
languages like python invest or
not always at the top um i'm sure this
is something you've considered and i was
wondering if you
could speak more to what google's doing
um
so one of the things is we're trying to
try to identify an original source of
you know we want to we want to show
original content ahead of anything that
is simply
uh duplicating it or not adding value to
it so that that's one of our goals and
we have systems that are designed to do
that they're not always perfect but
that's th
they're always being improved and it's
not even a new thing we've we've
constantly refining things that we're
already doing
um we even do things like allow sites
that if they distribute their content um
we'll recommend to them to use things
like what we call the canonical tag it's
not just our tags anybody can use it for
any kind of search engine but it's a way
to indicate if someone were to have
permission to use your content to
duplicate it somewhere else that they
effectively point back and say no no not
just a duplicate the canonical is over
here so think about that in terms of
your ranking purposes
so
we do that sort of thing we do huge
amount of spam work including trying to
catch content that's simply scraping
other people's content and not you know
there's there's no value that that's
gone with it
um like a huge amount of work
so
it's very much top of mind to just keep
improving on that sort of thing and you
know there's examples where it's not
happening i'm always happy to hear them
because it's not perfect but it's by no
means sort of a back of the mind type of
thing it's very front of the mind
there's an entire group of people who do
nothing but look at both spam issues and
also then just look at how we improve on
original content issues
thank you
anything more
okay
um i want to thank you all really for
your contributions
um
danny thank you
um
it was uh
very helpful to understand what was
going on
and dmitry thank you for uh taking the
time to make a post and
say what you thought was the important
thing here
and uh i think that
uh you're you're out there really trying
to make uh
space in the uh
in the in the
internet for
small
personal bloggers and provide support
for them i think that's a that's an
admirable choice
and
you know i wish you the very best of
luck
um i think that uh
what you're trying to do is in fact one
of the directions the web is clearly
going
um
google is uh
has some real advantages in the sense
that it is huge it has
in a bunch of uh web crawls that are uh
uh second to none
and i
my complaint about google right now is
that not all not all things that are
clearly in the web crawl always appear
in the answers on the uh out of the
index
that is because the crawl is so large
uh things now get lost you know i
i didn't think i'd ever encounter that
but i thought it four times in the last
month
that seemed to me to be just
an unreasonably large
on the other hand
if it were 10 years ago
i wouldn't have found anything at all
that i wouldn't been able to show that
it even existed so
um in any case thank you very much